don't you as well you get some video
games
what unit which way my favorite game did
the permission when you walk down the
stairs the issues of the camera angle
doesn't change so you everyone who tries
to do it just spins up and down these
days punching Foley actually because it
just doesn't put you see you're so weird
why are you so weird why does he want me
to move I don't wanna move
here you hold this sure sure
we haven't seen anyone in this house yet
that no [ __ ] someone said I move yeah it
was just a game to let me know if I
didn't think that I do
Oh sister trying not to breathe for the
brief to keen to please but apparently
there's Potamus where if you do move I
had two people call that stop saying it
said that I've moved and I barely did it
a character died so when that stuff
happens I have to really not move well
someone could end up right
Michigan I think I should have listened
to it my second time wasn't listening
really neurologists I actually know if
he's back up
are you really freaked out
two more songs invited ya
Yeah right
she's convincing me I know that's not
our just think that's the point
yeah-ah swipes yeah I don't want to
discover your boss now noise yes exactly
right
this this is all thanks thanks let me go
first check
Chris yeah well he knew okay so that's
in YouTube this movie crap down there so
well the bad guys don't you would stay
with us yeah this is actually who likes
person
it seems like bad idea if they don't
maybe playback yeah then up to but I
reap the whole thing I didn't tell
anyone I was controlling it I control
the whole thing I've done it without me
it's very you sure look something else
wasn't reading it really sure we only
have what to the pendant yeah but I
managed to do it and no there lies that
I was controlling all the people of
flavors I didn't think so bit perhaps
did you get an answer that no it wasn't
the answer - yeah yeah yeah I love
isolation and loneliness it's my
favorite food no you don't either do you
know it looks like a long time yep so if
I was in this game and would probably
don't wanna be alone yeah something else
yes
how do I feel about people who are
afraid of loneliness people are afraid
of blood this is a question yeah I don't
I don't feel either of those neither I
don't certainly don't despise it so I
guess yes they're closer to sympathy I
tended me I don't feel angry no I think
it's really all kind of a surprise for
me I don't know I didn't either
good okay
okay it's a each choice we're making
changes does but I don't feel I'm sure
absolutely
skip price okay anyone in particular on
my face man I like this kind of I would
say honesty yeah see what's on the desk
that it was an absurd meeting hard it is
and as far as I know that's because
they're to you you said you were scared
of that's not cool yeah it's for a man
but we don't spend of gold wreckage on a
toilet
so from this bottom middle skin what
question you would tell the truth even
if it results in what does anything mean
what is that what is that question what
is it asking me do you can't compare
those two things perfect very cherished
I think that I would still say loose tea
okay those do I think what he was asking
us was would you tell the truth even if
someone's going to be offended and I
think your answer is none and - yes
probably so let's see if we can get a
middle ground resort didn't you I traced
the phone talk to know can we have
something like a maybe yes maybe I will
either above Oh
so what Carcharias to be eight hopefully
result
so I'll take care of you and sliders you
can anything about the state charity
yeah okay this cake my well we'll just
have to see what goes us scale like this
yeah actually you know the thing that
snapped in front of Mike that you didn't
see you know I didn't say that that
might have been a Stamper would that
would be fitting apparently around blown
its women Clark us before Donuts we're
supposed to find a male this which is
probably Justin Mike otherwise it did
not happen kid justice yeah screwed
something up a guy Ashley max not never
late for me to go yeah we know we're in
something so her she's been paying
attention I'm sorry
give me a pic she's doing the first
question so what do we learn flip into
series don't care that's what I would do
in that situation is anyone there
if you can hear my voice give us a sign
you're not okay okay is anyone there
wherever there is hold on I don't know
what it is we're supposed to help them
right how can we help you
winning I think we really need to find
out who's trying to communicate with us
hmm we can't help you if we don't who
you are can you tell us who you are
[ __ ] looking up yeah yes that's true
that's cool it's gotta be yeah sister is
it
she's not gonna kiss this that I feel
like it would be best that we do that
hmm are we seeing that is that you
Oh see this is I mean anything because
one of them could be controlling it Josh
are you sure no dude it's cool I want
you and it says so insist it's saying
help an insane city we can find out what
happened
what happened to you all of my sorry
that's still funny
Oh we'll only hit one G that she doesn't
smile always sorry but she can't respond
out straight so pointy
yeah yeah we don't know if this
Jebus really like you so if he's angry
at them variable assistance think he's
already angry well which is painting a
narrative innocence confirmation bias
and trying to convince myself I was a
bad guy
but that was totally a dead person
standing in that moment respect but but
notice the dust yeah amongst the
ridiculous despot but I think you know I
thought that it was just bad guy but
apparently that's like that was ghost
and I think that was real it wasn't one
of them reading it yes
so she's not that so she didn't scream
because she fell
yeah but I also don't want her to die
like I think she's an idiot but I don't
want her to die like Emily at least
you're losin your man up douche but he
said I was scared I'm sorry he's the one
that's afraid of my solution yes grumpy
you seem scruffy yeah
oh no this is the same sort of Lila
individuals blend dog police actually
approaching them but again we don't
actually know I'm feeling like he
doesn't see whether at the monster thing
yeah so I knew would again hit them -
yeah dude again I think that I have a
pretense but you wouldn't have seen a
trailer for this game or anything no I
don't know but I think that he had to
kill oh well I sure do miss some things
but I feel like getting the name soda
but yeah they could be two separate
people we know it certainly that point
your guy is yes
it's Victor the dragon
come on there
just waiting for jump-scare long time
yeah we didn't get more than I was even
expecting your jumps yeah it's still
good
well no it was it was just your made
over this way thank you giant footprints
yeah actually looks like the way you
guys I'm snow good yeah it should be
involves goddamnit
and the either explorers dismiss or
something then I think that they would
like ghosts I think it was [ __ ] how
long did it take them to get here yeah
seems a second yeah this is the girls
cabin very well just who the girls will
sit fine it was somebody they ran
through it's not that's definitely
dismissed sure scared I'm sure
their shape
see that's a little unfortunate because
think a little bit from that are saying
that it is actually that you guys don't
the Kevin that that went through bridge
through it and this is just like just
check back into the big now yeah you
like made it sound like some kind of
Sexton you know it just giving no doors
wouldn't Longley and nobody is fiber
neat no no damn it should make sure he
forced them into hibernation no sense of
wolves there's some instability errors
that say do you know is this all
happening separately
sinem windows down Nick point Yemen from
launched come here come to get a thank
you kids did
how how they're going to do this is a
Sony bud break its neck anything a
person exposed but I think I press the
ex post accidentally
so if you see one of those and you come
up in answer just say it as soon as you
can because yeah
get inside that's the only option there
is quickly topic yes that deer's head
should not act like that no which means
it's ready
he reminds me of me so do you take a
movement in the ceiling yanked out and
then Victor Jason I feel like it wasn't
something's don't be - yeah
so no that's not better might have a
wolf but how do you and won't start tend
to approach people and I think Steve
Wilson tennis friends well yeah that
makes if the conductivity yes the square
but I think like when I went to press
with your urgently I press the expert so
for missing part of it yeah but I feel
like that probably update will sent me
some choices we just made it gonna have
an effect on the things which we expect
so what was telling you it's like over
two
different endings it's just that most of
them at the same well very similar it's
something critical yeah it's the selling
point for me and really it's because
anyone can play and have a totally
different thing though did you say that
no I didn't say yeah yeah I think that's
clear a lot of replay value actually
yeah you can take two compacity are
different yeah so it's not a game that's
played to the interplaying that can be
game that could be replayed yeah and
when it lets you go back and replay the
chapters individually so we're on two
three I think right now okay isolation
and it would let you choose like this
chapter because no one's died yet so we
could like choose an earlier chapter to
go to